let's go even put your face on in the
car
sorry good work drama and oh my god whoa
I was really looking for to go in
cross-country skiing with the family oh
I get it
we're lying we're engaged
congratulations Thanks
your profile said you work in the film
industry that's cool or we could take
two video oh god no
uh my ex-boyfriend just walked through
the door you want to make him really
jealous no that's not at all I want to
touch the shoulder no permission to talk
okay
well are you Ashley Driscoll
yeah it's hayfields oh my god look at
you you look you know so much older
Thanks it's your 30th birthday I don't
want to make a big deal about it I'm
just gonna be this weird sad lonely cat
lady that turns over sexualized birthday
cards let's have a party yes please
please let us know your party all right
well keep it very small classy even hmm
what is happening you crazy idiot um if
you think it's a small antique book of
Kate it's melon taste all sigh you
scribing Olsen twin nuts and often be
they blow up
this would be what you got Wow
didn't recognize me and my weekend look
did you have you seen that girl you even
I was just about freeze party fire fight
it fight it fight it fight it fight it
yeah I can do it there was wet